okay so like two and in part two I will
talk about the count sketch algorithm
which is the algorithm that has come up
in David's David's talk where it was
used for subspace embeddings but here we
will use it to first get some basic
information about data streams in
particular to approximate the top K most
frequent items in massive data streams
and once we have that which is a
classical application we will design a
spectral specification algorithm for
graphs that operates through sketching
and is applicable to dynamic streams
okay good so there are three parts to
this I will first remind you how count
sketch works and in general how one
solves the heavy hitters problem on data
streams after that I will introduce the
notion of spectral specification of
graphs and actually design a spectral
specifiers in with optimal space
complexity in from from linear sketches
good so heavy hitters can't sketch here
again we're looking at the following
basic problem we are given a pass over a
sequence of data items just like this
and we're also given a parameter K our
task is to figure out the key most
frequent items in this data stream
okay so here's an example of a data
stream and perhaps if K is one well we
want to be able to figure out that three
was the most frequent item all right
well one way of solving this problem
would be again to store the entire data
stream that always is the option but we
would like to have storage on the order
of K log n so case the number of
elements that we are looking for and n
as the universe size that the elements
come from well this sort of storage or
space complexity will not be possible in
general it will however be possible
under some natural assumption on the
frequencies of the elements in the data
stream okay why do we care
again a classical application is
estimating IP flows through a router so
again you have a router picture down the
slide and the source destination pairs
are being observed by the router and
know instead of supposed to instead of
trying to understand how many distinct
pairs are communicating the router wants
to know which source destination pairs
contribute the bulk of the traffic
and we would like to figure out for
instance the top few elements say if K
is 2 then we want to know that there's a
pair that communicate 5 back isn't
another one that communicated 4 packets
and we want space complexity on the
order of K log n whereas the universe
size all right
good nice so our goal is to design the
following primitive we want to be able
to scan the stream of data items and at
the end of the day return the top k most
frequent items rather at every point in
time one should be able to stop us and
ask to report the K most frequent items
so one can call this the fine top
operation that takes a stream in the
parameter K well it's actually more
useful to think about point query
operation a point clear operation is
this it's a data structure that
processes a stream then at the end of
the stream it is given an element I and
just asked well how many times did the
ithe element appear and it should be
able to output FI the number of times
item right here appeared or at least do
it approximately indeed if we have a
point query primitives then it's not too
hard to maintain the top K most frequent
items just every time an item arrives
this is a very powerful primitive so
every time an item arrives we could just
ask this primitive how many times it
arrived so far and
okay so what we're really interested in
is there's a designing approximate
versions of these primitives because
they can actually be implemented as in a
small amount of space so for instance we
are interested in returning the top key
most frequent items approximately let's
say those that that whose frequencies
are not substantially smaller than the
frequency with which the case most
frequent item arrived and we're
interested in designing an approximate
point query primitive which does not
quite give you the exact number of times
a given item arrived but has some error
and we'll get into the precise error
bounds in an envelope okay
what we'll do is obtain a space
efficient algorithm that finds the most
frequent items or so to speak the head
of the signal assuming that these
frequent items contribute a bulk of the
bulk of the stream in l2 sense to be
defined in a minute and quite
interestingly this will be exactly what
you need
in order to design spectral
specification algorithms for graphs okay
so here is our stream arriving
and what we will do is we will assume
that the elements are ordered by
frequency so element one is the most
frequent one and the frequencies do not
increase if we're interested in the top
K elements
we'll call the top K elements the head
of the signal and we'll call the rest of
the tail so the head of the signal here
is the the green guy's and the rest is
the tail the tail will basically
contribute noise to to all about
Oh so how do we solve this problem well
to solve this problem we'll first design
a very simple estimator remember that we
want to design a small space data
structure that mean maintain some kind
of representation for stream and at the
end of the day when given element I
tells us approximately how many times I
arrived so let me design a simple basic
estimate estimator with a constant space
complexity and analyze its position this
is very similar to the AMS sketch and
the general counts catch algorithms do
to check our others so this is what I'm
describing we choose a random hash
function that map's our universe so
let's assume that our items come from a
universe of size m to a plus minus 1
uniformly around and our simple
estimator will be this we'll just keep a
counter and as soon as an item arrives
the way we process it is we increment
the counter by exactly the sign of this
particular item this is really just
computing the dot product of the
frequency lecture of the stream with a
random sign vector and so this is how it
process the stream when we're asked to
estimate the earth element then what we
do is simply take the counter that we
have multiplied by the random sign and
output that
okay well how good is this estimator
well first this estimator is unbiased
which is nice why is it unbiased well
because ultimately the estimator was
computing just the dot product of the
frequency vector of the stream with the
random science so since we are
multiplying it by the random sign of the
ith element this is just the sum over
all elements J in the universe evgeniy
times the sine of j times the sine of i
ah separate out the contribution of the
earth element where the signs get
squared and what we observe is that the
noise term which is the contributions of
the other elements from the stream is at
the following form it's a sum over all
other elements of the stream of the
frequency of that root times a random
sign the signs that signs are
independent and random plus minus one so
an expectation this noise term is zero
that's very nice
so our estimator indeed is unbiased just
take the expectations of both sides and
we observe that the expectation is fi as
needed
good yes Oh a great question question is
how much independence do I need for this
calculation or for this particular
calculation all I need is to weigh as a
pairwise independence like everything
that I used was basically the
expectation of the two sides for
different elements is zero good so so
that's just the unbiased the fact that
the estimator is unbiased but we also
want it to be close to the true value
with a good probability well for that we
just bound the variance in the variance
of our estimator is what well we know
that they already wrote it in a fairly
convenient way namely the true answer
plus some noise term who coming from the
rest of the elements so the variance is
just the expectation of the noise term
squared
and let's understand what this noise
term looks like so the noise term is the
sum over all J other than I sign of J
times sine of I times the frequency of
gom-tai things squared so we can open up
the sum and we got the double summation
over all pairs coefficients J and J
prime other than I all right that's
that's very good
so if we take the expectation of this
what we see is that again the cross
terms vanish ah if J is a distinct from
J prime then the expectation of the
product of the two signs is exactly zero
and so the variance of our estimator is
nothing but the sum of frequencies of
elements other than I squared all right
very good um so here's a quick summary
of our algorithm so far we have an
unbiased estimator and we know that the
variance is the sum of squared
frequencies of the other elements of the
stream
so by chebyshev's inequality we know
that with a pretty good probability our
estimator actually is close to to the
true answer how close is a good question
specifically actually it is non-trivial
be close to the true answer if the
element fi dominates the stream in l2
sense namely for instance if the square
of fi is much bigger than the sum of
squares of the other elements in the
stream then this is a non-trivial
approximation
okay alright so that's a very simple
basic estimate let me get the actual
count scheduled now we can boost us into
a in actually useful algorithm which is
exactly constant the quell sketch
algorithm performs this estimate on yes
to get the to get that last inequality
you need more than the pairwise
independence right hmm to get the bounds
of
sparrows Independence's is good enough
- or the noise term again yeah
don't usually need always I guess for
this yeah this is the moisture right so
when you might deploy so we have four SS
appearing somewhere yeah
but si is always there right yeah what's
so let's go over this carefully right so
si is fixed it does not really depend on
the identity of the element in the noise
term
good so you square the sum si is squared
and what remains is the elevators so as
if the if the signs were not if the
signs were if there were if those are
not random science which will say random
Gaussian type I think the confusion is
because when you want to select two
estimation usually for voice Gretchen
yes
okay good ah very nice
so now we can boost this basic
estimation a basic estimate into an
actual full album mm-hmm how do we do
that well if we just realize that we
have an estimator that is correct
and that gives us gives us a good bound
assuming that our element fi dominates
the rest of the stream in l2 sense if
there are some of squares of the other
elements is smaller than of a square of
Fi
so what do we do what we do is we hash
our stream or split it into several
independent several streams
independently using a hash function and
apply the simple estimate to every one
of the substrates now specifically I
choose random hash functions H 1 H 2
through HT that map our universe into B
buckets B is a parameter here and think
of B is a large constant times K may be
10 K so remember if we want to
approximately say the top K elements
then if we hash them into 10 K buckets
then every given element with a good
probability will be alone in the bucket
so the noise term will not even most of
the times have any other head elements
it'll mostly come from the tail okay
good so we choose these team dependent
hash functions and T will be logarithmic
because we'll take various mediums later
and T random hash functions again a
logarithmic random sine functions now
the algorithm itself can be described as
follows basically the state of the
memory of the algorithm is a matrix just
tiros those corresponds to every
independent repetitions of this process
or the rows correspond to independent
hash functions and B columns the columns
correspond to the pockets good and now
the updates work as follows as soon as I
receive an element I what I do is let's
say I have received element 5 I look at
where 5 hashes in every single one of
the T hash
so five perhaps hashes here in the first
hash function here in second etc and for
every hash bucket I maintain this basic
estimator that we just designed I add
the element I with the corresponding
sign to the appropriate entry of the of
the hash table
oh no good remember that we're trying to
figure out the top key element yet so I
haven't really formally said parameters
but if I want to approximate to have a
good approximation of the frequency
counts that will allow me to mmm that'll
allow me to have a good approximation to
the top K elements think of hashing into
ten cables maybe more depending on the
structure
any any questions about this alright
good so every bucket in every hash
function is just an instance of the
basic estimator and now at the end of
the day if we're asked to produce an
estimate of the frequency count of item
hi what we do is just look at every
single hash function check where our
item hashed the corresponding cell if
the hash table contains an estimate for
the frequency count of our height so we
return the median of all these
estimators sorry very nice so what can
we say about the precision of this
process we can say something is
something of the following form well
first by the previous analysis for every
hash function the individual estimate
for the frequency count is unbiased that
we know and furthermore we just computed
the variance and we know that the
variance and the variance here is with
respect to the random science for every
every one of our estimators that is for
every single choice of the hash function
H R we can write down the variance with
respect to the random science of the
estimator for frequency FY so by our
previous analysis the variance in the
corresponding bucket in the Arth hash
function is exactly the sum of squares
for the frequencies of elements in the
stream that hashed into the same bucket
as I under the earth hash function
except for I itself
all right very nice so and that's where
the note that at this point we didn't
really use the randomness of the hash
function this is a statement that is
true for any choice of the hash
functions HR well now since we're around
hashing randomly into B buckets it can
be easily shown that typically and with
a good probability with high constant
probability the variance term with
respect to the science is about one of a
B fraction of the sum of squares of the
coefficients of the entire city indeed
what is the probability that some
element J hashes to the same pocket as I
it's 1 over B if our hash function has
enough independence and that's how we
get good and now a simple application of
churn of bounds shows that if we do
we'll say hungry login repetitions and
take the median then the estimates will
be correct the estimates for all items I
will be correct up to this square root
of 1 over B times the sum of squares
term with high probability
simultaneously for all items okay very
nice in fact one can do a little bit
better you here's what one can do
remember that we if we're hashing into
more than K buckets then in fact the
variance is typically not just one of a
be of the sum of squares of old
coefficients it's not just one of a be
of the l2 squared norm of the signal in
fact one can tighten up the analysis to
show that the variance most of the time
is a 1 over B fraction of the l2 squared
norm of the tail that is one can ignore
the top K coefficients that's because
most of the time our item I doesn't even
have seen the same bar to say
all right very nice so that's that's
what we have we have an algorithm that
is essentially an approximate hash table
that lets us approximate the frequency
of any given element up to about 1 over
1 over square root of 1 over K if they
l2 squared norm off the tail of the
signal yeah and this is the count sketch
algorithm uh let me just make some
remarks as to how powerful this is no in
fact this is a surprisingly powerful
primitive because of to to to put this
in perspective let's just imagine the
following situation I suppose that we
have a stream where one element element
number one the Pierce square root n
times the streamers is length n and
element number 1 appears root n times
and the remaining and minus root n
elements are distinct so the frequency
vector has a single entry which is one
which is root N and then all the other
entries are well ok and now let's set B
the number of elements that buck is that
we hash into to some large constant well
note that the tail of the signal over
the sum of squares is most M so if B is
a large enough constant then our
estimates are correct up to say about
squared and by 10 which means that with
only order log and space were able to
figure out that element 1 is the
dominant as we're able to resolve the
frequencies up to a square above the bow
to squirt an additive term and that is
quite remarkable because if you think
about it element 1 only appears root n
times on the stream so if you were to
sample a uniformly random element of the
stream you would pretty much never see
this element so the l2 squared the fact
that the error bounds are in terms of
the square norm of the signal is a very
powerful effect
okay good so in particular this fact
that the error are the error bounds for
counts cash algorithm can be phrased in
terms of the l2 squared norm of the
signal makes it ideally suited for
applications in spectrum of the spectral
specification of drops that try to
understand this so there is a sense in
which you're saying l2 sketching is
counts is better than l1 tan is it some
monotone function of P are these sets
that you're returning simply growing
monotonically as you please be a second
a second so l2 heavy-hitting is it a
superset of asset return by the elevator
for some well I see I see I see
oh good so I guess l2 is strictly
stronger than l1 for instance if you if
your K is constant because the you know
they they error for instance if you do
so the error bounds for l2 heavy-hitters
depend on the l2 norm of the tail and
though two norms are all tuned off
anything is at mostly a 1 norm of that
very same thing so if you're estimating
a constant number of elements that
indeed l2 is better okay there are some
caveats here for instance this assumes
that the precision let's say the
precision parameter epsilon is also
constant because the they did not do
that but the dependence of your space on
the precision epsilon is 1 over epsilon
squared for account sketch whereas it's
only 1 over epsilon for countyman so
there are another where there isn't a
sweeping statement here
like you don't lose the epsilon like
you're gonna get the same epsilon for l1
else yes yes yes if you do l2o too
sparse right if you if you don't want L
infinity L too right
no just any heavy hero's algorithm with
their tail guarantee you will well two
will give you an l1 heavy terse
algorithm and you don't lose in the
epsilon disk is like and use it using
the same space yes using the same space
in terms of Epsilon
so I won't for instance L infinity all
two and I will need one over epsilon
squared for one of our epsilon squared
dependence right to finally have some
heavy here maybe there is fellow one you
can find it with because if the tail is
maximized when you have some
maximization and this saves you in fact
we reverse the line yeah but basically
say also for l2 you can try to compare
l2 l2 sparse recovery to a 101 sparse
recovery and so for constant case l2
tails are better than one tails but if
for instance you think about L the
sparse recovery problem then also the
way you measure error on the head
changes so there isn't a sweeping
statement there
yeah okay so special specification of
rough so let me come back to the problem
of approximating cuts cutting graph
suppose that I have a graph and think of
this graph is arriving and in a dynamic
stream and I want to approximate various
cuts in the graph well as we as we saw
before if I have some cut in mind then
the value of a cut is can be viewed as
the l2 squared norm of this vector Z
where the vector Z is the vector of is
the vector of differences between labels
and vertices where i encode my cut as by
0 1 length so in fact if I think of
encoding cuts and graphs by vectors X
that are just indicators of this cut
then the value of a cut is nothing but
the l2 squared norm of the vector B
times X where B is the edge incidence
matrix of my graph now this is also
known as X transpose B transpose BX or
in other words the quadratic form of
applause Ian effects
B transpose B is also known as the
operation of the graph it's the diagonal
matrix of degrees minus there Jason C
matrix
okay good so ecology prime is called an
epsilon cut specifier for graph G if the
laplacian of G prime is multiplicatively
close if the quadratic form of the
laplacian of G prime is multiplicatively
close to the quadratic form of the
laplacian of G on all cuts mainly for
all vectors X that are binary and with a
fundamental result of carbon and bands
of carbon 96 shows that any graph G that
admits a cut specifier with about n log
n edges specifically order 1 over
epsilon squared n log n edges
okay the more general notion of
specifications of a more powerful notion
of specification is something that's
introduced by speed one and tang
in 2004 one says that a graph G prime is
a epsilon spectral specifier of G is if
the quadratic form of the laplacian of G
prime is sandwiched between a slightly
scaled up version of the quadratic form
of flow plus GN of G and a slightly
scaled down version of the quadratic
form of the laplacian of G on all
vectors X mainly not just on cuts but on
all fractional vectors in other words if
G prime is a spectral is a cut specifier
of G if it approximates all cuts
multiplicatively to 1 plus epsilon
factor and it's a spectral specifier of
G if it provides this approximation on 4
in the positive semi-definite sense
namely the laplacian l prime is between
1 minus epsilon L and 1 plus epsilon L
in the PSD sense in the sense positive
semi-definite all ok so this notion of
spectral specification has found a lot
of applications in the recent years in
particular to numerical linear algebra
combinatorial optimization and many
other questions we know this is a result
of Spearman and tang and that's few-
Rostova that not only does every graph G
admit a spectral specifier with about n
log n edges but we can also also
construct them in nearly linear time and
nearly linear in the number of edges in
the graph good however the algorithm
must feel its permanence Rostova lets us
construct the spectral specifier if the
graph is residing in memory of a
computer that is in the RAM model and
now suppose instead that the graph is
actually given to us as a stream of
edges is it possible to construct a
special specifier while maintaining an n
log N or so memory footprint at all
times namely in the streaming mode and
so let me tell you how to do that in
particular we will use the the the
account sketch algorithm
various points in the in the analysis
alright so how does one generally
construct spectral sparse affairs of
graphs well the c1 answer also suggested
this natural important sampling
algorithm for constructing the spry
Safari G prime for you take the graph G
look at the edges of G and for every
edge compute some sort of importance
parameter and use this importance
parameter as a sampling probability it
computes sampling probabilities for
edges of G and then every edge is
sampled independently with that
probability and if you sample an edge if
you if you included in G prime you'll
give it weight 1 over the sampling
probability to make the estimator
unbiased furthermore if the sampling
probabilities are chosen to upper bound
affected resistances in the graph then
one can show that not only is the
laplacian of G prime equal to the
Wauseon of G an expectation but it
actually is properly approximate the
laplacian of G and the positive
semi-definite sense all right good so
here for every edge the effective
resistance of the edge is well the is
exactly the potential difference induced
on the two endpoints if I treat my graph
as an electrical network and inject one
unit of current into one node and take
take that unit of current out of the
other node so the correct sampling
probabilities are essentially scaled up
versions of effective resistances so for
a night ii i compute the effective
resistance multiply that by its a
hundred log n divided by precision
parameter squared and if that's bigger
than one i make it one what i will show
is how to implement this algorithm using
linear sketches and an optimal amount
near the optimal amount of space
good alright so first just to give us
some intuition how would I how would any
reasonable algorithm for specifying a
graph G work and so forth one of the
properties that it has to satisfy well
for instance if we have a graph G here
on the slide and you know there's a cut
that is crossed by only two edges our
algorithm probably has to include both
edges with probability one into the
sparser fogger and indeed it is the case
because effective resistances are upper
bounded by inverse connectivity's so
edges that some edges can be more
important than others
on the other hand if our graph is
reasonably uniform then just a random
sample load all right so our task is to
maintain a specifier in the streaming
world so again we're given an poly log
in space and a single pass over the
stream the edges arrive and after
looking at the graph of taking one pass
we want to be able to output a spectral
approximation okay so as stated this is
for insertion only streams and for
insertion only students the problem is
not particularly hard it is not hard to
convince oneself that offline
specification algorithms are string
about in the insertion only model the
intuition is is basically this if you
are able to specify prefix of a subset
off the graph then if more edges are
added to this graph edges that you threw
away because they were unimportant don't
become more important ah
and this intuition can be turned into
reasonably simple
insertion only specification algorithms
if you want the right sample space
complexity on one needs to do more the
question that I would like to ask is
suppose that my graph evolves
dynamically so edges can be both
inserted and deleted gilliland construct
spectral specifiers in optimal space yes
resistances okay so the question is how
can we compute effective resistances as
the graph comes in online are all
computing them exactly as generally we
don't know how to compute them very
efficiently exactly
so what is what is useful okay so what
is useful here is the following so
here's a very simple algorithm for a
spectral specification and insertion
only stream streams that doesn't really
use much but what you do is this you as
the graph is coming in you buffer let's
say n log n edges or a buffer and you if
you have some space bound you buffer as
many edges as you can and then you
specify this graph down to n log n then
you buffer more then you specify the
Union so you sort of construct the
binary tree on the on the stream and you
can check that with with only a
logarithmic overhead in the precision
and space you you will you will succeed
in specifying but what I had in mind was
more algorithms of the following form
for instance note that if I have a graph
and I compute effective resistances in
this graph and then somebody adds more
edges to it the effective resistance has
only go down this Israelis man ethnicity
principle and this can be exploited to
to get space efficient insertion all
this
okay so we're more interested in the
question in this problem when we have
deletions in the stream and indeed the
same hard example that we had for
connectivities of course applies if
there are some edges that look important
at some point in the stream then you get
more edges making these unimportant and
then something can get deleted so we
will need to use linear sketches but the
linear sketches need to be used in more
interesting ways for example for the
spanning tree problem we designed a way
of recovering all the edges in the graph
that cross small cuts that is have small
connectivity using a small amount of
space but now our problem is harder
because in particular it is not hard to
construct examples of graphs where one
can have an edge II that does not cross
any small cut and at the same time has a
fairly large effective resistance and in
particular needs to be included into the
sparsa fire with probability one pick
one simple example of such a graph is
just take a graph which is a cycle so if
n vertices on a cycle and connect
vertices imj to by an edge if I minus J
in the cycle distance is let's say less
than n to the one third so this gives
you a graph which is fairly dense so the
average degree is about n to the one
third and then you add an edge that
connects antipodal points but one can
verify that the effective resistance of
this edge will become about a constant
so in particular the algorithm has to
figure out these global dependencies in
the graph edges not across any small
cuts the min cut is after the 1/3 but
it's it still needs to be found all
right good so how does one construct a
spectral specifiers through linear
sketch we will essentially implement the
result of Spielman and see Rostova using
sketch so our plan is to learn how to
approximately compute effective
resistances of edges somehow in
sketching model and sample edges with
probability is proportional to effective
resistance
okay one thing to note here is that in
particular this is the scheme that we're
using a very simple problem that we
certainly have to solve is the list all
the edges of the graph that have
affected resistance at least one over
log n that is large effective resistance
edges and this is really what I will
mostly talk about
okay so in general what we need to do is
somehow designing a sketch s times B
such that from that sketch we should be
able to compute the sampling
probabilities for each edge and sample
edges with those particular
probabilities now there are some
challenges that we certainly need to
overcome because for instance I only
have a sketched version of the graph so
I don't even know which edges are in the
graph so I shouldn't be able to compute
something for abilities for all the
edges and somehow I need two samples
okay so this problem of designing a
sketch from which you can sample with
probability is proportional to affect
the resistances seems a little
challenging so let me introduce a simple
problem first so a simple intermediate
problem is is the following I want to
design a sketch and I want to assume
that I have a strong hint but besides
the sketch let me assume that I'm given
a crude approximation to my graph if I'm
given explicitly some graph G tilde that
provides some constant factor
approximation to jail say a factor of
million an approximation okay so here's
this G tilde it's a reasonable spectral
approximation
given my sketch and this graph G tilde I
want to be able to get a very good
approximation to if this factor C was
actually 1 plus Epsilon then I would be
done I could return G tilde but I want
to improve you tilt it to something all
right
so that's what I would like to solve but
even this seems a little a little
challenging at the moment let me
simplify it even further let me just say
all I want to do is design a sketch s it
goes into a small number of dimensions
that simply allows me to recover all the
heavy hi effective resistance edges now
remember those edges that have effective
resistance at least one of all again
they have to be taken with probability 1
so at the very least I have to be able
to figure out these
so let me let me see how to do that okay
and so this is the point at which we
need to understand what effective
resistances are and how they are they
can be related to l2 heavy hitters in
general the effective resistance between
two vertices U and V and my graph is can
be expressed as follows
well it is is the potential potential
difference induced between the two nodes
U and V when I send a unit of flow from
you and take it out Utley in particular
you can express it as v UV l plus b UV
where l+ is the pseudo inverse of the
laplacian and b UV is the vector of
demands for our flow so I want to send
one here inject one unit at here and
take it out at V so b UV is just 1 at U
and minus 1 Utley this is also known as
the UV 'the column b transpose u v is
the UV throw of my edge incidence matrix
okay
all right so if I imagine sending one
unit of flow from into your from vertex
you to vertex V this is an electrical
flow so this will be a potential flow
that is the flow on any given edge will
be the difference between the potentials
induced on that
so the potential fee is nothing but the
pseudo-inverse of the laplacian times
the demand vector consequence so here's
an example of a session session
experiment suppose that I am looking at
a pair UV let's say u is this note of
the blue node and V is this red node
here I'm trying to send one unit of flow
from u to V here is this electrical flow
and the amount of flow carried by
various edges is indicated by the
thickness of the edge now an electrical
flow is a potential flow so flow on an
edge XY is just the difference of
potential
the flow vector itself hence is the
matrix B at the edge incidence matrix of
my graph times the vector alright so now
finally here is the characterization of
effective resistances that will be most
useful to us one can prove using this
relation and something else that LH e is
a high effective resistance edge in the
graph if and only if the following
happens if I try that if I want to send
one unit of flow from one end point of
that edge to the other then a
non-trivial fraction of the flow in
terms of his energy has to be going
across that particular edge so the
effective resistance of an edge is
nothing but the energy of the flow on
that particular edge divided by the
total l2 squared norm of the flow so for
instance if this is the electrical flow
from the fortitude of this vertex V then
a non-trivial fraction of energy goes on
this edge hence the Edge has higher
higher effective resistance there is now
equipped with equipped with this
formulation of with the definition of
effective resistance I am now able to
relate this to l2 sketching and get an
efficient space efficient way of finding
all heavy effective resistance sessions
oh good so let me design a very simple
primitive recall but I'm assuming that I
have some reasonable approximation to my
graph and I want to design a sketch of
the edge against enough districts such
that if later like once I have sketched
the graph and process the stream if
later somebody gives me a pair UV and
asks me is it true that UV is an edge in
the graph and the effective resistance
of this edge is not really large then I
should be able to answer this question
okay so if I have a primitive of the
sort then I can just go and test all the
edges and at the very least I will have
a list of edges that includes all the
edges of high factory resistance this
definitely looks like pros
okay so here's my plan for recovering hi
effective resistance edges I'm giving
you an D and what I will do is I say
okay let me route the optimal electrical
flow from u to V one unit of flow this
is a potential flow fee so let me
compute the potentials I will compute V
equals L inverse times B UV there's a
problem here because I don't really have
L inverse but we'll deal with this later
this is my ideal plan so I will get the
vertex potentials once I have the vertex
potentials what I will do is I will
complete compute the flow vector I will
take the edge incidence matrix
multiplied by the vector of vertex
potential very nice and you know there
is an issue here as well there are two
issues I don't know the edge incidence
matrix and also the flow vector is very
large and choose two well that's quite
sighs it was fine if I could compute the
flow right sure but the only thing I
would need to do I would need to look at
the eighth entry of this flow vector
it's an N squared dimensional thank you
and check if it contributes at least to
one of our again fraction of the l2
squared mass
all right so here's an example so if
this is my U and this is my V this is a
edge that is in the graph and it has
high affected resistance so let's say
this is electric that roughly to bring
to the floor vector E if I look at the
corresponding entry it contributes a lot
of mass on the other hand if the edge UV
is say not in the graph
well this vector is just zero the
corresponding entry is just zero because
the corresponding row of the edge
incidence matrix was zero okay very nice
so this is a reasonable plan but there
are a couple of issues with this so one
issue is as I alluded to earlier that I
don't have the laplacian and I don't
have the B on the other hand this is
exactly why I assumed that I have some
reasonable suppose a reasonable
approximation to my graph turns out that
instead of instead of finding the
potential vector that corresponds to the
optimal flow in the in the actual graph
G it's enough to find the potential
vector which corresponds to the
electrical flow in the approximate graph
in the approximation and just use this
potential vector instead instead of the
actual we get a vector of potential
difference is Delta it's no longer a
flow vector but it doesn't really matter
okay okay so this this problem was
partially solved the fact that I'm using
a crude approximation to G hurts me a
little bit but not too much this was a
constant factor approximation and one
can show that the characterization of
effective resistance is still holds you
lose a factor of C on the right hand
side this will go into your space but
it's a constant factor so that doesn't
okay very nice but so still there is
this issue that is as stated I want to
compute the entire vector of potential
differences okay on the other hand I
didn't want the entire vector all I
wanted to know is I'm given an entry of
the sector I want to know is it true
that this entry contributes a 1 over log
and fraction of the total l2 squared
mass that is something that we can use
solve using the count sketch algorithm
that from the first part of this talk so
let me restate the guarantees that we
got we got the following algorithm but
we didn't quite phrase it in this way
but but almost
suppose that I have a vector of reals
think of this n choose two length vector
of potential differences we say that an
element in this vector is l2 heavy is an
ultra heavy hitter if it contributes at
least an ADA fraction of the l2 squared
mass we already designed an algorithm
that for any beta is able to sketch the
vector Y down to dimension about 1 over
ADA times the poly log think of 1 over 8
is the number of buckets that you hash
into in the count sketch algorithm and
from the sketched version of the signal
we can recover all the heavy hitters
furthermore well we didn't show that you
can recover do the recovery very
efficiently in fact one can even run
recovery in time they're roughly
proportional to the size of the sketch
volleyball factors all right so this is
something that you can get from count
sketch
okay good and now we have pretty much
pretty much have the algorithm modular a
few other tweaks but so our question is
this remember that we have this vector
of potential difference is Delta and we
have some of some edge in hand and we
want to know if it's a heavy edge and l2
sense in this vector dot so it would be
really happy if we could have a sketched
version of Delta s times Delta of course
the problem is that I don't know okay
since the since since we're interested
in learning whether or not the edge
contributes at least to one over log in
fraction of the mass the space
complexity of that is still a poly log
now the only issue is I don't really
know Delta in advance but it's not a
problem because we have linearity that's
why we're using linear sketches I can
just sketch the B remember the Delta is
just the edge incidence matrix sometimes
some vector of potential C so if so the
Delta is B times C so if I had s times B
which I can maintain because s times V
is has a poly logarithmic number of rows
and n columns then I can just take the
sched matrix multiplied by the vector of
potentials and I will get a sketch off
of my vector so note that this is
different from the connectivity version
because in the connectivity version we
were just adding up the collar columns
of the matrix now we're really adding
them up with non-trivial coefficients
and this is this is the final algorithm
is we maintain and L to have a hitter's
sketch of the edge incidence matrix and
compute the vector of potential
differences based on the other graph G
tilde the post multiply the sketched
version of the edge incidence matrix by
a vector fee and run heavy hitters on it
okay very nice ah so that lets us test
for any given edge whether or not the
edges in the graph yes
we constructed ill children ah no but no
no one yes so uh what is easy ah
excellent question the question is so
far I'm assuming a major hint namely I'm
assuming that I somehow have a crude
approximation to my graph the question
is how can I get this crude
approximation that's the content of the
next few slides okay so note that this
basically gives us a way of recovering
edges that are heavy and l2 sense and
have a high vector resistance but in
reality recall we actually won't needed
to sample edges with probabilities
proportional to affect resistance so if
there is some edge that has a small
effective resistance let's say about 2
to the minus J for some largest J then I
can't really figure out if this edges in
the graph because it'll at best
contribute a pretty small fraction of l2
mass I can't resolve this using my outer
heritage however remember that we only
needed a sample of these edges what one
can show is that if I have an edge of
effective resistance for roughly 2 to
the minus J then if I take a sample of
my graph at rate 2 to the minus J then
if the edges survives the sampling
process that will end up being heavy
with extremely high probability so those
edges that were sampled I can recover
with high probability all right so
ultimately this gives us the following
the following following algorithm we
store l2 heavy-hitter sketches of
subsampled versions of the graph and the
sampling is geometric rates
if I have a spectral approximation to my
graph G G tilde then for every potential
edge in the graph I do the following I
look at an edge a B and I first I first
compute an approximation to its
effective resistance using this crude
sparsa fire then once I have this
approximation let's say it's roughly 2
to 2 minus J I look at the corresponding
sampled version of the graph and I check
if the edge is there
it's the edges there I included in the
sparse afire with and give it weight 2
to the J's and I repeat this an
appropriate number of times okay good ah
yes I'm sorry I did not quite follow how
you you got from only getting too heavy
here to taking care of the children
minus J right okay the question is how
do we either good the question was how
do we get from just recovering the heavy
hitters to sampling edges I try to to
the minus at rate proportional to their
effective resistance I do this very
quickly here's the main statement it is
not possible to find to list all the
edges of effective resistance to the
minus J for some large J because there
are just too many of them the same time
we only wanted a sample of such edges
suppose that you proactively sample the
edges for example all the edges of your
graph independent theater ate 2 to the
minus J one can show the following yes
you sample all the edges right so
example all the edges you sub sample all
the edges with up front
Oh for all you choose a geometric
sequence of sampling rates yes let's
take two to the minus J sample all the
edges with probability two to the minus
J dependably yes and now if you if you
have some edge you want to check now
you're interested in the following
question
is it true that the edge actually was
included in the sample and the edge had
higher effective resistance
- - - jr. so I have this edge it has
effective resistance - to the minus J
one can shell is a somewhat non-trivial
lemma that if you if you had an edge of
effective resistance to to the minus J
then if it makes the sample it will be
heavy in L two cents and the subsampled
vector remember that we're running heavy
hitters on the flow vector that is and
now we're just running heavy hitters on
the flow vector but that contains only
those eight entries that made the sample
so you can show that if you sample at
the right rate and if the age survives
it will be heavy and hence it will be
listed so that the estimate of the
effective resistance for the sample will
be sufficient ah I see no you don't
estimate the resistances from the sample
you estimate resistances from this crude
approximation I have an edge I can first
compute using that crude approximation
what its resistance should then I look
at the appropriate sample and I know
that if the edge is actually there then
I will recover it with hyperbole so
you're running out of time so all right
good so now now back to your question
about where you get the crude
approximation from yes where do we get
the crude approximation from it turns
out to be more useful to not just think
about specifying G itself but to think
simultaneously about solving several
specification problems suppose that for
every lambda define G of lambda to be
the graph G with a lambda fraction of
the complete graph added to it so it
looks like this lambda is small is
pretty much G if lambda inverse probably
small then it's pretty much G and if
lambda is large then this looks very
similar to the complete graph
you get the chain of sparsa fires and
lambda doesn't need only needs to range
between say 1 over N cubed and one
because the smallest eigenvalue of any
graph any unweighted graph can't be too
small so one event keep you all will do
the job
ah so this was now considered a
geometric sequence of lambdas so that's
the logarithmic number of number of
graphs G lambda note that adjacent
graphs in this chain are spectrally
similar they're similar up to a factor
of 2 in the other hand at one end point
you have the pretty much the complete
graph so you have a graph that is very
well to a factor of two approximated by
the complete graph and at the other end
point you have something that's pretty
much G so now you can use the complete
graph to specify G of 1/2 you you get a
good approximation to G of 1/2 you use
that to specify G of 1/4 and this goes
on and on and a logarithmic number of
steps you reach G 1 over polygon and
you're done ok good and so this
basically concludes the algorithm or
note that
again similarly to the spanning tree
algorithm this this takes and poly log
and space which is nearly optimal and we
use a linear sketch and at the end of
the day we decode the sketch using the
fact that we can recombine rows of the
sketched agency Tass matrix do you have
to pass through the data for each worth
by now oh right excellent question the
question is that if this decoding here
looks like an iterative process and
indeed it is an iterative process that
goes goes over a logarithmic number of
steps but we don't have to access the
data here because you prepare the
sketches first so similarly to the
spanning tree algorithm but remember the
spanning tree algorithm also was a log a
procedure that ran for a logarithmic
number of steps but it could run on the
same data so here we just use prepare
enough sketches and then you can run the
adaptive decoding on the very same same
days okay good all right so let me just
summarize I gave I gave some summary of
classical sketching algorithms and some
nice applications of these algorithms to
graph or processing in massive data
streams and the main idea was to use
primitives for dealing with vectors such
as l2 heavy hitters and distinct
elements in a MS sketch on the edge
incidence matrix of the
um there is a lot of very interesting
open problems here generally we're very
interested in understanding what is the
power of linear sketches for other graph
or primitives in general the saloon is
sketching paradigm it has been very
successful in the last few years and we
do understand the status of some
problems so for example we do know that
it is not possible to approximate
imagines in single a certain single pass
sketching set there's a single pass
dynamic streaming setting one pretty
much needs a quadratic number of bits
and lower bounds for these problems our
user usually proven via a connection to
simultaneous communication complexity on
the other hand of for spanners so for
other fundamental graph properties such
as say design a small space sketch that
will approximate the shortest path
metric of the graph we have reasonably
good algorithms if for the setting where
adaptivity is allowed that is if I can
look at the stream several times I can
take one pass or I can generate a sketch
right here take one pass over the stream
then based on what I observe generate
another sketch and do this several times
but we for instance for spanners we
don't know what the state's complexity
of this problem is in the single pass
setting that is is there a non trivial
oblivious sketch that approximates the
shortest path metric of a graph using
small space there are also applications
in sub graph counting and other problems
one also very interesting direction is
proving lower bounds for sketches in
multi path settings for problems like
matchings we have sketching lower bounds
that go through interesting construct
constructions from additive
combinatorics difference and solutions
and rata graphs these constructions
however seem rather fragile and it is
not clear how to derive multi pass lower
bounds from them so see similar low
bonds are known for for for the set
cover problem but
for drug problems like latching system
there's many exciting open problems I'd
be happy to talk more about them thank
you yes
so if you were to do something along
life like a secretary problem of like
peeking at the first part of the history
when they'll bring it out or not using
that change is there like an analog for
the secretary problem in this sort of oh
I see very interesting I good so not in
the sketching model because I'm finding
a little hard to imagine how this would
fare in the model with dynamic updates
because here I'm thinking of a
worst-case ordering of edges and with
insertions and deletions so if you look
at half of the stream it's not clear how
much this will really tell you however
it is possible in the insertion only
setting which I didn't get to talk much
about to use randomness assumptions to
to get small space algorithms for
example we know how to use a random
order stream to essentially emulate
sampling from it to approximate matching
size using poly logarithmic space to a
pretty good factory and we a lot of
results of this sort a very recent very
interesting recent result that seems
similar to what you're proposing is a
result by is all one thing who show that
if you have a stream of edges of a graph
in a random order
then you can compute say an additive
epsilon approximation to the number of
connected components in the stream in
something like 1 over epsilon to the 1
over poly one over epsilon space so
these algorithms have the flavor of look
at half the stream and do some sort of
an estimation and compute yeah it is to
use a chunk of the stream to perform
statistical estimation I'm sure that
there are other things that you can do
the spectral specifications that she
described is it the time but what is it
I see the question is what is the time
complexity of the spectral specification
are the algorithm that I described
assuming free randomness runs in
quadratic time can be made to run in
quadratic time so there's nothing
published that I know of that does
better than that
[Laughter]
let's thank all the speakers
[Applause]